la tradición modificada por una
enfermedad inesperada tenés que bing o
el día de acción de gracias este año
genera incertidumbre y algo de miedo en
eeuu el habitual desfile de la tienda
meses en nueva york' fue limitado a ser
visto de forma virtual para respetar las
medidas de distanciamiento social
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en esta oportunidad del desfile sólo
recorrió unas pocas cuadras de la gran
manzana el día de acción de gracias es
una de las grandes fiestas que une a los
ciudadanos y residentes en eeuu aquí se
reúnen para cenar el tradicional pavo en
un acto de agradecimiento por las buenas
cosas que ocurrieron durante el año con
casi 13 millones de casos por ccoo y 19
en la unión americana y más de 260.000
muertes por el patógeno este 2020 ha
supuesto un reto para el desplazamiento
de muchas personas sin embargo algunos
no se dejaron amedrentar y están
recurriendo a los centros de pruebas
para poder viajar y llegar a tiempo a
otras ciudades viajes que podrían
incrementar el número de contagios una
semana después boom aquí llegan regresan
a la escuela y punto así que esto está
ligado con lo que antecede en la
comunidad y con lo que ocurre a nivel
social y la pandemia también ha
dificultado la entrada económica de
muchos que han tenido que recurrir a la
generosidad de otros para poder comer
luego de semanas y meses del hobbit y
todos estos problemas de desempleo es
lindo ver el sentimiento de pertenecer y
la forma en la que les dicen a los
voluntarios y a todos que se unan y
organicen todo esto me hace sentir
importante y merecedora
hoy a pesar de la crisis sanitaria
los estadounidenses ponen sus esperanzas
y agradecimiento para que las vacunas
existentes sean efectivas